- So thank you so much for joining us
for Climate Change & Global Development:
Net-Zero after COVID-19.
This is the seventh in a series
of Yale's Development Dialogues
which are virtual panel discussions
hosted by the Yale Economic Growth Center,
the South Asian Studies Council
and the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs.
And as you may know, if
you've joined us in the past,
we look to lessons from
history and economics
to address today's policy problems
in low and middle-income countries.
I'm Catherine Cheney,
I'm a journalist focused
on global development
and I'll be your moderator today.
And I'm joined by panelists
including Sir Dieter Helm,
who's professor of economic policy
at the University of Oxford,
and former independent chair
of the UK Natural Capital
Committee which provides advice
to the government on the
sustainable use of natural capital.
Plus, you'll hear from
Rohini Pande, Sunil Amrith
and Rory Stewart who are organizers
and co-hosts of this series
and I'll introduce them in just a moment.
But first just to set up the topic,
the topic of green growth
has come up a few times
over the course of the
Yale Development Dialogues
and there's been some debate around it
but we haven't really tackled this head on
and that's what we'll be doing today.
So in climate negotiations,
low-income countries have long asserted
that they are being asked to
sacrifice economic development
for a problem that's largely caused
by high-income countries.
And today, western countries
set bold emissions targets
even as they continue to
import goods manufactured
in low and middle income countries
at a high environmental cost.
So countries like India
may in fact increase
their reliance on coal
to help mitigate the economic devastation
caused by the coronavirus pandemic,
which of course has really
become a crisis in India today
even as they set targets for
renewable energy production.
I should note that this
dialogue is being held
on Yale Climate Day which is
a full day of virtual events.
This provides an opportunity
for the Yale community
and the public to come together
around pressing environmental challenges.
And you can click the link in the chat
if you're joining us on Zoom
for details on other events today
including John Kerry's
keynote this afternoon.
As I mentioned as people
were still signing on,
for those of you joining us here on Zoom,
please do submit your questions throughout
using the chat or Q&A function.
And now I wanna go ahead
and introduce our panelists
and move into discussion.
So earlier I mentioned Dieter Helm.
His most recent book,
"Net Zero: How We Stop
Causing Climate Change"
addresses the actions we all need to take
to tackle the climate emergency
and we'll hear more from him on that.
Sunil Amrith is the Renu
and Anand Dhawan professor
of history and current chair
of the South Asian
Studies Counsel at Yale.
His research focuses on histories
of environment, migration
and public health across
South and Southeast Asia.
Rohini Pande is the Henry J. Heinz
the second professor of economics
and director of the Economic
Growth Center at Yale.
Her research has examined
the political economy of aid
and empowerment of the
in developing countries.
And Rory Stewart is a
former member of parliament
and secretary of state
for international development in the UK.
He's written extensively
about travel, politics
and development and
argued against the merging
of the Department for
International Development
and the Foreign Office
now known as the FCDO,
you may be familiar.
So I wanna begin with a
question for each of you
just to get your take on the
topic we're addressing today
and then we can dive into details
of what you have to say and
get into a conversation.
But I think we all agree.
We might not agree on the path to this
but I think we all agree
that the traditional methods
of growth must change
in order to address climate
and development goals.
So the question is, and this is where
there might be some
disagreement and debate,
what are some of the hard
decisions that need to be made
and who needs to step up?
So just to get your take on this topic,
let's begin with Dieter,
if that's all right.
- Well, thank you very much
and thank you very much
for asking me along to this discussion.
So almost all discussions
about environmental concerns
start with the question of the
economy and economic growth.
And the alternative is put
forward as either green growth
or no growth, club of our own thought
that we should have no growth at all.
My take on this is that
growth is perfectly plausible
provided it's driven
by technology and ideas
and that the scope for the advancement
of human ingenuity of
technology is enormous.
However, we can only consume
at a level which is consistent
with sustaining those
opportunities through time.
So the fundamental
environmental observation
to kick off with is we are all living
beyond our sustainable
environmental means.
In other words, we are consuming too much
and the level of our
consumption has to adjust down
before it can continue
to go up into the future.
And why is that?
It's because you and me are
ultimately the polluters
and we're not paying the
cost of our pollution
including carbon emissions and the like.
And whether those emissions
are caused in India or China
or Africa or they're caused in London
is irrelevant in the
climate change example.
So we have to step up and pay
the costs of our pollution
and recognize that we're
responsible for far more pollution
than we're currently causing.
And that leads to some
pretty hard decisions
because of course,
politicians around the world
from Biden to Johnson, to
Von der Leyen in the EU
are all promising to boost consumption
to solve our current economic difficulties
from the coronavirus.
And simply boosting
consumption is not a model
which is going to deliver
the kinds of environmental
adjustments that need to be made.
We the polluters have to adjust down,
and then we have a proper
level to work on this
but the politics of
that are extremely hard.
- Thank you.
And when you mentioned
we're all living beyond
our sustainable environmental means,
I know your book outlined
some steps that can be taken
which we'll get into in our conversation.
But I'd love to go ahead
and bring, let's see.
We'll begin with Sunil,
if that's all right.
We'll bring Sunil into this.
So again, I mentioned that
you and Rohini and Rory
have been part of conversations
over the course of this series
where the topic of green
growth has come up.
And I wonder if you can expand on
based on maybe historical
perspective as well
which I know you bring to this,
what do we do now that
we're at this crossroads?
Who needs to step up?
What hard decisions need to be made?
- In some ways, Catherine,
I think the hardest decision
is the way you put it just now.
You said, we all agree.
We all agree,
but I suspect a lot of
the world does not agree.
And I think that the hardest task
is in fact a profoundly political task.
And that is the task for
those of us who believe
that a new way of thinking about growth
and the relationship between the economy
and environment is necessarily.
The task is one of persuasion really,
because I think there's a big disconnect
between the kinds of conversations
that we've been having on this dialogue
with a wonderful audience engaging with us
and the conversations that are
being had around the world,
not just in the developed countries
but also in developing countries
about who should sacrifice,
about what priorities
are particularly in
light of this pandemic.
- I think you're absolutely right.
And so if that is a barrier persuasion
which I think it is,
hopefully in our conversation,
we can get to not only hard
decisions that need to be made
but hard steps that need to
be taken including persuasion
and consensus before we
can actually make progress.
So hopefully we can get into that.
Rohini, can I bring you into this?
What's your take on this topic
and Net-Zero After COVID-19.
How do we get there?
- Thanks, Catherine.
So I think I'd probably build off both
what Dieter and Sunil were talking about.
And can really remind us
that in some ways before,
there was economics that
was political economy.
And that really, I think is
what needs to be sent to stage
as we think about issues
to do with climate change
and how we are going to
get rich and poor countries
to possibly choose different
distributional burdens.
Sunil talked about persuasion.
I would add to it the idea of
how do we create incentives.
So how do we actually have policies
that incentivize rich countries
to do what is arguably good for the world
but perhaps may not be good for them
in some very narrow sense,
something I know you're
going to come back to
that we've already seen with COVID-19
and a lot of discussion
of vaccine nationalism.
The other issue I'd bring
up is that implementation.
I think a lot of discussions
of climate change policies
tend to be quite legal right now.
So a lot of discussion of having
different countries decide
what policies to put in place.
But when we look at I think the failure
of several of these
policies, for instance,
those are the Kyoto Protocol.
A lot of them have to do
again when we can institutions
then make it hard to
implement these policies.
And again, looking at COVID-19
and looking for instance
at the vaccine rollout in
India and how slow it is,
I think it's important to remember
that a lot of the issues are going to be
how do we have fair technology transfers?
How do we think about IP issues?
But a lot are going to also be about
how can the global community
helps trend and institutions
and how can citizens domestic countries
ask for the institutions
that will give them the voice they need.
- And yeah, I know you can expand on this
in our conversation
but I think if we look
at COVID-19 as a test
for how developed countries can
support developing countries
going through a shared challenge,
there are concerning
implications for our ability
to respond to climate change
given the challenges
we've seen with COVID-19
and global solidarity
in responding to that.
Rory, I'd love to bring you into this.
I know that your views on these issues
include your own experience
as working in policy,
working in development,
trying to work with countries
facing these hard decisions.
So what are some of the challenges ahead
and who needs to do what?
- Well, I'm really gonna come in on this
from the point of view of somebody
who was recently a
politician and a minister.
And I saw three different types of issue.
One of them is domestic to Britain.
So when I was running
to be mayor of London,
all the polling suggested that
the overwhelming majority
of the population
was not prepared to spend
15 pounds more a year
in order to pursue environmental policies.
So it's extremely important to understand
that domestic politicians running
are being told by that polling
experts and strategists
that this is not a way to get votes.
And if you think about the
things that we wanted to do
even at a tiny scale of London,
for example, on air quality
extend the clean air zone out
to the outskirts of London
which was going to pose a
cost of 65 pounds a week
on people with older vehicles
from low income families,
you could see why very,
very quickly in the election
people were reluctant to go there.
So that's first thing.
Second thing is the way in
which countries like Britain
deal with other countries.
In other words, the
bilateral relationship.
So I was very struck and defeated
by the enormous reluctance
from British development professionals
to really emphasize climate.
And the reason for that is
that their development models
very much dependent
particularly on energy.
So a lots of the programs
that they were most proud of
which they thought would
get the greatest results
in terms of getting people out of poverty
involved investing in coal
fired, heavy oil fired plants.
And when push came to shove,
when I started to block those projects,
so I started block money
going to a Shell Oil project
in Senegal, for example,
or I tried to stop the Commonwealth
Development Corporation
spending its money on large
fossil fuel burning projects
in Africa, there was huge
pushback in almost reluctance.
Even though the development
community acknowledges that
a lot of the impacts of climate change
will be felt very, very drastically
by some of the poorest people in the world
in terms of flooding, in
terms of solar iteration,
in terms of heat, right?
And the argument made by the
most senior person to fit
is that by dealing with climate change,
we were punishing today's poor
for the sake of tomorrow's poor.
And then the final point
which we can turn back to
which I think Rohini, Sunil
and Dieter have all touched on
is the way that this is actually perceived
from other countries,
and how much India may be reluctant
to accept these type of moves.
But to take it even more
extreme, think about Afghanistan.
When I walked across Afghanistan
in the winter of 2001, 2002,
there was literally no electricity
between Herat and Kabul,
none at all.
And as Afghanistan tries to develop,
obviously they're trying to
generate some electricity
but this is a country
of 30 million people.
If Afghanistan began to go on the path
of trying to generate
the amount of electricity
that a European country
of 30 million people got
and that that was repeated
cause you cannot imagine
the scale of the problem
we're creating for the world.
And yet, can you imagine
trying to say to Afghans,
no, no, no, I'm sorry,
this isn't gonna happen.
Okay, so on those three
points, I'm gonna stop
'cause everybody else
was much shorter than me.
- Well, I do have one
follow-up question for you
which is when you're facing
that kind of pushback
and that statement as you said,
by dealing with climate change,
we're punishing today's
poor for tomorrow's poor.
It's hard to make change, right?
Even just institutionally,
no matter the change,
it's hard to make change.
And you mentioned that
these energy projects
which within defeat, there
were a lot of champions
for these energy projects
in terms of their development outcomes,
the environmental impacts were negative.
If you're making that kind of argument
and seeing that kind of pushback,
it seems that it would be helpful
to point to examples of what could work.
And can you give some
examples what could work?
What could be a win-win for development
and for the environment?
- I mean, it is true that you can do
some extraordinary renewable
energy projects now
much more cheaply than you
were able to a few years ago.
So I went to see this
extraordinary wind project
in Lake Turkana in Kenya
and I went to see some
extraordinary solar projects
in Jordan.
And they are generating
electricity in Jordan
from solar panels at
an incredibly low rate.
But I just want to dig
into that a little bit
because of course, one
forgets how politics matters
even with something like a solar panel.
So although they were
generating electricity
from these set of panels much more cheaply
than they were generating
extras from anything else,
they weren't building anymore.
And the reason they weren't
building anymore was politics.
The Arab Spring had led to them
losing their fuel supply from Egypt.
They then sign the series of
contracts for 20 or 30 years
with big international oil companies
to produce carbon produced
the energy into Jordan
and they couldn't get
out of those contracts.
They had to pay the money to
them every year, regardless.
But there was no point of
building more solar panels
for domestic consumption
and they couldn't export
because all their export lines run
through Syria to Turkey and
Iraq which had a huge demand
for the type of power
they were able to produce.
I just wanted to bring that to bare
because it's very tempting for
students and others to think,
okay, well, why don't we
just can't give Michele
the solar of panels,
and Mali with set of panels,
Jordan with set of panels.
But when you actually
get into these problems
the way the contracts work
and the way that the politics
and conflicts in neighboring states work,
these things become much more difficult.
I'm sorry, I'll try and
be a bit more optimistic
in my next time.
- No, that was great, Rory.
And I want to bring Rohini in
because India came up earlier.
And just in terms of zooming
in on what this looks like
and how politics are
involved as Rory mentioned,
Rohini, can you provide
us some perspective
looking at India.
- Well, I see a train passed
from outside my house.
- I'm timing with a train
passing through, okay.
- But let me jump.
Actually, I wanted to just
follow up on Rory's point
on solar pricing and
actually talk about some work
that one of our colleagues here at Yale,
Nicholas Ryan has been doing right now
on solar pricing and growth
of solar energy in India.
And I think the point he's made is that
green energy suppliers now increasingly
have as reset low what we
would call variable cost.
So they still have a large fixed cost.
This is partly the case
also that as you're thinking
about alternative forms of energy,
we often have to think about
how they're going to fit into the grid.
So what this has meant
in the case of India
which is a federal country,
that if you're a producer of
say green energy supplier,
you have to contract
with the state government
in order to say, I will give
you so much solar energy
that'll go into your grid.
But what this means is that
most electricity distribution companies
at a state level in India
are terribly bankrupt
for a combination of political
economy and other reasons.
And so there's a huge concern
of basically renegotiation and default
by the state electricity companies
which will very often not be
taken to court the same way.
And so this has led to in general
quite a lot of counterparty
risk for green energy suppliers
when they're trying to go
to the state government.
So they're very willing in Nick's work
right now to sell to
the central government
which seems to be doing better here,
but very unwilling, very
often to go to those states
that are actually the poorest states
that are just beginning
to put in place grids
when you really want from the start
a transition to green energy.
But those are exactly the states
where the suppliers don't want to go
and because they're the most concerned
that they will not be
able to recover that cost.
So I think that's a good example
of saying that very often
we look at technology and we say,
wow, look at the price of solar.
It's falling so fast.
And we have to actually think about
what actually is a good to take
for the suppliers to provide it.
As Rory said, sometimes international
but even within a fast-growing
country like India,
it can be institutional
barriers or just risks
that means people won't tend to.
- Absolutely, I write
a lot about technology
and global development.
And there is a lot of promise
when it comes to technology in this space,
but that what will it take question?
Many barriers stand in the way.
And speaking of that, I
want to return to Dieter now
and hear a little bit more about your book
and what you lay out in the book.
And I know you talk about what citizens
and governments can do to cut carbon.
And we've heard a little bit from Rory
about some of the challenges
working in government,
Rohini expanded on that.
I'd love to narrow the focus
to citizens for a moment
because earlier you were talking
about this as a shared responsibility.
And for citizens in low
and middle income countries
in particular, I'm curious
kind of building on Rory's point earlier,
what should they be asked to give up?
Again, many challenges here
in terms of asking people to
do things for the environment
that might not be in
their own self-interest
or in the interest of their country
from a development perspective
but I'd love for you to
expand on points in your book
in terms of if we are all to take action,
what does that action look like
from the perspective of citizens
in low and middle income country?
And you're on mute.
Yeah.
- Use the same lock in the end often yet.
It's important if you are
citizens to do things.
And I deliberately focused on citizens
and not just consumers
and I'll explain that point in a moment.
You have to make sure
that what they're doing
is gonna make some difference
and it's actually going
to address the problem.
So you have to start back at the beginning
with characterizing what the
climate problem is, where it is
and what would be necessary
to crack this problem.
So the first thing to say is
almost all the discussion
is about emissions.
But then the number that matters
is the concentration
of carbon in the attic,
the stock and the other greenhouse gases.
It's sequestration and emissions,
and its emissions net of sequestration
which adds to that concentration.
So it's just as important to talk about
what's happening to the Amazon
and how you protect the
natural assets around the world
as it is to talk about what
comes out of a coal postage.
It's not that the coal
postage is important,
it's just that we shouldn't be
exclusively focused on emissions
without thinking about sequestration.
The things like rainforest
in Brazil, it's both,
it's admitting a hell of
a lot by burning it down,
but it should be
sequestrating a lot instead
and oceans, phytoplanktons and so on.
So that's the first thing to say.
The second thing to say is
anyone who thinks one more heave
and that'll I'm sure lead
to a discussion about COP26
has to explain how a bit of recent history
doesn't fit that model.
So every single year since 1990,
we've added two parts per million
to the concentration of
carbon in the atmosphere.
There isn't a blip for the
financial crisis in '07, '08,
and there was no blip last
year during the lockdowns.
And that should really give
people pause for thought.
If you do all of that to
the developed economies
and still you are two parts
per million to the atmosphere,
we really have to look at
this problem very hard.
I mean, I'm happy for
everyone to have meet up
for 17,000 people to rock up in Glasgow.
I'm very pleased that politicians
are talking about climate change.
But anyone thinks that Paris
really cracked the problem
and this is the icing on the cake.
They're not in the same universe as me.
Now, the next thing that's very important
and this is back to which citizens, okay.
If you look at current climate change,
nearly 30% of emissions
are from China, okay.
China has more emissions than
Europe and the United States
put together now in the
share of total emissions.
These are staggering numbers, okay?
And what's more, it's building
more new coal power stations
than all the coal power stations closing
in Europe and in America.
Good to that is it's important,
but it's in proportion.
And that the current growth rate of China
let's say five to 6% by
235, there'll be two Chinas.
So to get a real grip of the
magnitude of the problem,
think about a world in
which you just go off shore
from the East coast of China
and there's another one
and it looks very much
like the existing one.
And that will probably
be true of India too
as India's growth rate goes
back up to five six and beyond.
And you can just do the arithmetic.
So these are stunning numbers.
So if you go into that context and say,
so what does it take
to crack that problem?
Well, if you just look at emissions,
you think it's the Chinese,
it's all their fault.
I've heard politicians
say those things privately
going forward, okay.
So there are two things to say about it.
One is that a lot of those
emissions are for you and me.
So the Chinese model is less so now
but it was built on an
export orientated model
as an Indian model may be going forward
following on from Korea,
Japan, and Germany
in the periods after the
post second world war period.
So you have to make sure
that the people who are
actually causing those emissions
to be made actually are the people
who are paying for those emissions.
The piece I'd add on top of that is that
if you think climate
change is gonna get solved
between now and 2050 or beyond,
then it's almost not all
but largely going to be
in terms of additional
contribution to climate change
gonna be coming from
China, India and Africa,
and Brazil, Philippines, Indonesia.
These are the rapidly
growing areas in the world.
And if they do rapidly grow
with high levels of emission,
whatever the justice of that,
we will face that very hot climate change.
So if we are really interested
in making these changes,
we the citizens of the countries
with much higher consumptive per head
have to make sure we pay for the emissions
in those countries.
And now what do their citizens do?
Well, I'd put it the other way around.
What are their citizens entitled to?
So I say citizens because
in my environmental approach
what I want to do is to
make sure that all citizens
have the basic capabilities
to function society.
You can see that I did my
thesis under much ascend
to see where this argument comes from.
So it's a positive entitlement
to assets not utility,
not the economist normal currency,
it's making sure they have the wherewithal
within which to live their lives.
The most important wherewithal to do that
is to have the natural capital assets,
environmental assets to
make their lives tolerable.
The only way that's gonna happen
as the Indian Energy Minister
made clear a couple of weeks ago
is that there has to be
substantial transfers
to make that possible.
And I think the most
frightening thing about Paris
and they need the
discussions about Glasgow
is that people are talking about,
well, couldn't we go from
100 billion to 200 billion
to address the transfers
that might be required.
We in Britain spent 300
billion just on COVID, right.
This has got an order
of magnitude different.
And the difference between
the COVID it episode
and the climate change
one is the COVID one
enables an element of
national wool building
and nationalistic protection
which we've seen that lives.
There is no wall you can build,
not even one that Mr. Trump could imagine
which will keep a ton of carbon emitted
anywhere out of the
world into our climate.
So I think we have to
think about global citizens
and their entitlements,
we have to think about
isn't assets not flows
and we have to think about it
in the capabilities that go with that.
Not just trying to make them happy
and think it's some of you tyrant exercise
in maximizing economic welfare.
- Thank you, and I'm glad
you brought up this point
around natural capital which
I hope we can return to
because I think too often,
it's presented as a trade off
in terms of protecting
the planet at a cost
to your country's development path.
But when you bring in natural capital
as a lens through which to look at this,
you can identify more of
these win-win opportunities.
- A very quick come back on that.
So a lot of people who
think there's a trade off
between the environment
and economic growth,
between that capital
and GDP tomorrow, okay.
And at the same breadth,
they'll accept that what
we're currently doing
is unsustainable.
So the conclusion that follows
from something that's unsustainable is
it will not be sustained.
And the problem is and the
problem of convincing people
in Europe and the United States is that
the people who are really
gonna get the bronc end
of it not being sustained
is actually not us.
We've got a lot of technologies,
we've got air conditioning,
we've got all sorts of things.
It's the poor that are
gonna get the consequences.
That's what makes the politics nasty
because it says, actually, you know what?
If we don't do what's necessary
to address climate change,
we get the effects last,
they get them first.
And that sequencing is quite important.
- [Catherine] Go ahead, Rory.
- Come in very quickly.
I mean, I think Dieter has
produced the very stuck
and very important thing there.
Remember it's also true to some extent
within wealthy countries that
it's often the poorest people
who are at the center of
this political problem.
But if you think of relatively
straightforward policies
that British governments
tried to implement,
for example, we tried
to increase fuel tax.
There was an escalator set up
where fuel tax was meant
to go up every year.
That was stopped.
The Labour Party campaign very strongly
on trying to control energy prices.
Because the people that
increasingly are the focus
of political activity,
could be the Rust Belt
in the United States,
could be the red wall voters
in Britain and in North East Britain
are often people who already feel
that their incomes have stagnated,
that there is extraordinary inequality,
that they are really struggling to get by.
And that basic things like running car
or heating their house
are taking a very large
amount of their income.
So many of the most
straightforward policies
that we would want to pursue
will have an impact on them.
And that's gonna also to relate
to something at the heart
of Dieter's proposal.
Dieter essentially is
proposing that there is a tax
on our consuming of these products, right?
So the more products that
we consume made in China,
the more that we will pay.
But of course the people
who will feel that most
are the people that are driving
a lot of the political discontent
and they're defining a lot of the politics
in Europe and the United States.
Thank you.
- Thank you, and on this point about,
I think Rory, you teed it up nicely.
It's not just about rich
versus poor countries,
it's about poverty and
inequality within countries.
I know that's something
Rohini can speak to.
Do you wanna jump in on this?
- Yeah, I'll just briefly jump in
and maybe also be a little
bit more provocative.
I think you can only go so
far if you think of this
in terms of geography and countries.
Because in the end, there
are many people in countries
like India and Brazil and even China
who are really not consuming very much.
And it may be that at the country level,
that's where the costs are,
but we have to recognize that
consumption of the poorest
is still something that
needs to rise a lot.
Recently I saw that was
interesting was a few years ago,
Bronco Milanovich had
made very well-known,
there's an elephant curve talking
about global income inequality.
I recently saw an Oxfam report that had
what they call the dinosaur graph
similarly showing how
emission's varied by income.
And showed that basically
if you try to do emission counting
not to the level of countries,
but at the level of individuals
you see the same pattern
that there is the rich who
are really consuming a lot.
So then what we need to
start thinking hard about
when we think of this cuts
is not to have all the
discussion at the country level,
but move it down to again
what I think is happening
in the income space
thinking about wealth tax
or inequality tax.
And the one final point
just to think about that is
we need to start thinking about
corporations and companies
as a component wealth tax.
So for instance, very often I talked about
how solar providers are finding it hard
to enter Indian states.
Nick actually has an earlier papers
showing how fossil fuel
companies tend to enter
these 30 year contracts of its states
and then renegotiate them.
So there wouldn't be many cases
where just as I think in
the income inequality space,
there's now a very robust discussion
about the need for wealth tax in the US,
some kind of corporate taxation in the UK.
We need to start thinking about
in the environmental space
at the level of what we think
are the large individuals
and corporations that are emitting,
not make it just about countries.
- So I want to bring Sunil in here
with a historical perspective.
India has come up a few times.
And as I mentioned earlier and
as many of you are following,
I'm sure as this country faces
the second wave of COVID-19,
it's a real crisis.
And Sunil, over the course of this series,
you and other historians have
linked different examples
of South Asian history to
current policy decisions.
And I wonder if you can
speak to whether it comes
to responding to COVID,
emerging from COVID
and tackling this issue of climate
and making these hard decisions.
What are examples from India's past
that might inform policy decisions
that need to be made now?
- I mean, it increasingly seems to me
that what we need in India is in a sense
nothing short of the kind of
foundational conversations
that were had in the
middle of the 20th century
which many of my colleagues
have been working on.
The sense of that
conversation in the mid '40s
to the late '40s when the
fundamental questions we're asking
what sort of politics,
what sort of society,
what sort of economy is this going to be?
I'm not optimistic that
political conditions
are particularly propitious
for that kind of conversation,
but I am struck by how much
of the unfinished business
so that earlier moment
we are now dealing with.
So that was a transformative moment.
The universal franchise
was introduced in a country
with profound levels of
social and economic inequality
which many people at the time
said would be impossible.
One of the things that did
not happen in the 1940s
and there's a very, very
interesting graduate student
at Harvard called Karen Kumba
who's working on this at the moment.
One of the things that did not happen
was nothing was done to address
the chronic underinvestment
in public health that
had been a characteristic
of the colonial state in India.
And throughout 20th century
and into this century,
India spends a smaller
proportion of GDP on health
than just about any country in the world.
We're seeing the consequences of that now.
And I mean, in some
sense, one of my puzzles
and this has been true
for many, many years is
why health has never really
been a political issue in India.
At the state level,
yes, from time to time,
but never it's not something
that wins elections.
This is something that goes back
to what Rory was saying earlier
about the citizens of London
voting for their mayor
were not perhaps willing
to spend even 15 pounds
to address environmental questions.
This is a much more puzzling question
because health affects everybody,
it affects the poorest most.
And this has not been a topic
at least maybe until now
for massive mobilization.
The other connection that I
want to make in terms of India
it goes to something
that Dieter was saying
that is very interesting.
So the Lancet found that in 2019,
air pollution was responsible
for 1.6 million deaths in India.
The year before, that nearly as many.
We're talking over two
or three years in India
as many people die from air pollution
as had died through this terrible pandemic
on a global scale.
I don't think it's an
exaggeration to say that
air pollution has not received nearly
as much media attention or
provoked as much anxiety
or concern as this pandemic.
So I think this goes to
what Dieter was saying
about there are no walls we can build
in terms of carbon emissions, for example
unlike perhaps some of what
we've seen with the pandemic.
So there are questions.
I'm not sure there are
lessons from Indian history,
but more sort of unfinished business
that we need to sort of
return to the fundamental
going to what Rory you were
saying, institutional questions,
political questions about how
to prioritize public health.
And from there to think
about public health
in a way that goes
beyond the emergency of COVID to the ways.
The causes of bad condition, for example
are far more aligned with
what we're talking about
in relation to the climate
crisis and energy consumption.
- Just very quickly say that.
I mean, I think there's
something very important
in Sunil's conversation about
that foundational moment
in the 1940s and '50s in India
because it's impossible to
get around the fact that
there is an ethical dimension to this.
Ultimately in order to
make our way through this
is going to involve some
very, very dramatic element
of sacrifice, transformation
and difficult choices.
And somewhere hovering
underneath the surface
of this conversation is the fact that
actually what Dieter and
Rohini have explained
is the impossibility
of generating massive
increases in consumption
and controlling climate change.
Which means that in the end,
our societies, our
politics have to find a way
of talking about morality.
Even as a politician,
I'm very, very conscious
of how easy that is to say
and how very difficult that is
to pull into an election campaign.
- Sorry, I'm jumping in a lot
but let me just jump in on
one thing that Rory said.
I think the implications
it also has for policy
and I love to hear Dieter on this.
We often have economists talk a lot
about the most efficient policy.
So for instance, we talk about carbon tax.
I think Rory very clearly pointed out
why something like a carbon
tax to fuel tax may not work.
And so this suggests that
even as we start designing policies,
I think we need to think a lot more
about distributional and fairness issues
as part of this ethical issue
which for instance may suggest
that sometimes rationing
which we think of as quite
an inefficient policy
may actually be one that
is perceived as fair,
and we should get to it.
So economists quite often talk
about what they would
call second best policies.
But they often think of second best
because there is some market missing.
I think we might need to think about
that what are the best
environmental policies
need to take into account
kind of issues of ethics
and morality of distribution,
and may look quite different
from what I think a lot of
economists right now are pushing
as sort of the
technocratically best policies
like carbon tax.
- Great points.
Quickly I'll just say we have
a lot of questions coming in
on exactly this
like what policies should
we see moving forward?
So this is great.
Go ahead, Dieter.
- So I very much agree there's
ethics at the heart of this.
And the way I kind of encapsulate that is
you have to work out how future citizens
are gonna have a seat at the table.
And they're gonna have a seat at the table
either because we haven't
made the sacrifices
and their seat at the table
is to make the sacrifices
or we're going to take into account
their interests going forward.
And my argument that we should ensure
that each citizen
inherits a set of assets,
natural assets at least
as good as they inherited
is an ethical principle.
But I also wanna pick up this point
that Rory raised about
fuel taxes, et cetera
and this link to carbon pricing, okay.
So it's very interesting.
As I understand it,
Mr. Biden doesn't want to
put off fuel taxes either.
It's not just the kind of UK thing
or a particular political party thing.
You tell the public, you know what?
It's better than a free lunch.
The climate change we're gonna solve it
'cause isn't gonna cost much of GDP,
it's all gonna happen,
the cost of renewables are
cheaper than fossil fuels.
It's like the 20 pound
loads lying on the ground
and we just got to pick them up
and it may actually be GDP positive, okay.
And I said to myself, is this likely
to which my answer is
absolutely no unfortunately.
Is it likely that we can transfer
from an overwhelmingly
carbon intensive economy
to one that isn't carbon
intensive economy within 30 years?
No.
And therefore you get to this political
what I call in inverted
commas lie which is
tell them we're gonna do it,
and tell them it isn't
gonna cost anything.
Mr. Johnson put this in Biden summit
a couple of weeks ago was saying
that he was going to have cakeism,
you could have your cake and eat it too.
That's morally irresponsible, right?
And we will have to increase the price.
And we can either do it
of carbon either directly
or having a carbon price.
And we do in Europe, we do in the UK,
actually most people have carbon prices
'cause they have energy
taxes in some form or another
or we can do it implicitly.
We can say, we're not gonna
take the most efficient route
because we don't like the politics of it.
So let's find a route
that's less efficient.
Well, the answer that is
gonna cost you even more
than the first route did, okay.
So I don't think carbon
pricing is impossible.
It exists.
Harmonizing energy taxes will
got us a long way towards it.
But the bit of our carbon
pricing that I really want
is the border adjustment
so that we don't pretend
amongst the developed countries
that when we reduce our
carbon territorial production
to net zero, we're gonna
stop causing climate change.
UK is 80% services.
We have no large energy
intensive industries left.
We pride ourselves as being
the leading country in the
world in reducing emissions.
This is the way to go guys, right.
And actually the truth is
our carbon consumption is
displacing our carbon production,
it's very much higher,
and that's because we're just not paying
for our true carbon footprint.
And paying for your true carbon footprint
is at the base of any
moral or ethical approach
to climate change here and anywhere else.
And since we're doing
most of the consuming,
and by the way we put up 80%
of the stuff in the atmosphere
that's already up there,
it's natural but it's our consumption
the developed countries
that has to come first to this equation
and not to tackle that by telling people
you don't have to have
a higher fuel price,
you don't have to pay for higher gasoline,
it's not gonna cost you anything.
It's just delusional.
And the consequence will be
that we will have that climate change.
And then back to the
early point of discussion,
the people who really gonna suffer
are in developing countries,
some in developed countries too.
But remember,
as witnessed in the Indian
case with COVID at the moment
compared with some of
the developing countries,
even the less well off in
the developed countries
have some kind of safety net
which unfortunately doesn't exist
in most of the world's population.
- Very true.
I wanna bring in some
questions from the audience
and we have some great ones coming in.
And I'd remind you all,
please use the Q&A function on Zoom
if you're joining us on
Zoom to submit those.
There is a question related to technology.
And I think we kind of started
with technology as a given.
Like we have the technologies.
And so it's about
persuasion and incentives
and hard choices, but a
question on that technology.
So what global adaptation
to green energy only happen
when cost-effective and
dependable technologies
make that adaptation desirable
without being forced
by government policies?
In that regard, isn't research
into critical obstacles
like energy storage and safe nuclear
the most important thing to focus on now.
So I appreciate the question
because again we kind of just plowed
through the technology point
and this forces us to
return to that question.
What more do we need
on the technology front
even as we are tackling
all these other issues
in terms of incentives
and ethics and persuasion?
Any thoughts on technology please?
- Can I have the go?
- [Catherine] Please.
- And I said technology
right at the beginning.
The reason why economic growth as possible
is because technology is pushing out.
And aside from Robert Barrow's book,
actually the evidence is the
speed of technical progress
has never been greater.
And this really matters for climate change
not just for the emissions
for the sequestration too.
So 25% of global emissions at
least come from agriculture,
soil on average has four times
the carbon of the atmosphere.
That's the biggest stock
of carbon is below our feet
and agriculture rips that out
pretty quickly especially,
unfortunately in some of
the developing countries.
If you look at what's
going on in genetics,
if you look at what's
going on in gene editing,
if you look at the transformation
that digital information
has created for agriculture,
that's a revolution it's making.
When it comes to the energy side,
there is of course great
technical progress.
The problem is that almost
all the hope and aspirations
are placed on two de-centralized
low energy density technologies
which cannot in themselves
produce the kind of power
required for the economy of the
world as it is at the moment
net loan what's coming.
I'm talking about wind and solar.
Solar by the way is much
more promising than wind.
You need a lot of wind
turbines and a lot of backup
and a lot of batteries
and a lot of storage
and all that's important.
But I think it's delusional to think
that we're going to solve climate change
with wind turbines and solar panels alone.
We need quite a lot more.
That requires an honest
discussion about technology.
First of all, the enormous resources
that ought to go into genuine R and D
which is a fantastically
on average good investment
for publics to make
even if the chances of each
one's accedence is quite small.
And we have to make some choices
about whether we're really
prepared to do this.
And I'm not advocating we
should without big scale energy
as well as small scale
and that means hydrogen,
nuclear and things of that sort.
And we're not there yet,
but we will not crack climate change
unless we have both the technology
and the adjustment of
the consumption frame.
Neither of them will do it on their own.
- Thank you, and thanks
for that great question.
Any other panelists want
to jump in on technology?
Otherwise we have other questions coming.
Go ahead, Rohini.
- I just have one quick thing
which it reminds me a
bit of sort of the focus
in the West coast, for instance,
in a lot of tech driven
for development policy.
I think 10 years ago this was the thing
that we were going to just
send money on mobile phones
and that was going to
solve all the problems
of redistribution.
I think one thing we discovered is
it didn't get the whole way there
not because mobile phones
are not an amazing good
or that sending money didn't help people.
But there were countries that
the regulatory agencies said
they didn't want to allow for mobile money
because they were worried about
risks to the banking system
and so on.
So I think my only note of caution
is I completely agree with Dieter
that we need, I think significant R and D.
But I think we shouldn't do it
at the expense of thinking that
that technology you need to think about
how are regulators going to react to it?
And they're going to be
willing to put it in?
And even technology can cause trade-offs
between short-term as already described
in a poverty reduction measures
and longer run returns.
You may have a great technology
but what it might ask the
country to do in the short-term
may make it politically very attractable.
And I think if we could start
having those conversations
or even think about them
at the time when you're
financing technology,
I think we could learn a lot
from at least what hasn't
worked up in development policy
despite great technological advances.
- There's another question here
related to the private sector.
And I'm loving these questions
because they're all very action oriented,
the role of technology, the
role of the private sector,
and I'll just preview in a
moment the role of universities.
There's a question around that
which I think would be fascinating
for this group to take on.
But let's talk about the private sector.
So the question is almost
a thousand companies
have signed on to the
science-based targets initiative
pledging to set emissions
reduction targets
consistent with the Paris trajectory
along with major companies setting
similar carbon neutrality goals.
So in what ways can
these ambitious targets
in private enterprise help support
and even spur governments to
step up their own commitments?
Can the private sector help lead the way?
Does it play a meaningful role?
Thoughts on that.
Rohini.
- Yeah, I can jump in.
I mean, I think it's great.
I think it's great to
see voluntary efforts
but I think we should think
about kind of the hard questions
at the heart of this.
But a lot of companies
really taking climate change seriously
is about losing money, right?
If you are a fossil fuel company,
there is no way that this is
actually good news for you.
So we have to recognize that
while voluntary actions
will get us some of the way,
it's not going to be the only way
in which private sector needs to be moved.
Sometimes you do need the state
to come in as the regulator
pushing private companies to take actions
that they won't want to.
- I think one other thing
to bear in mind also that
it's very easy for companies to announce
they're going to be net
zero by a certain date.
It's quite another when
you look beyond the bonnet
what they actually think
they're going to do.
And there are two parts of that.
First of all, remember
companies don't exist
for the fun of being companies.
They exist to sell stuff to you and me.
So when companies pollute, the
customer who buys the product
is actually the ultimate
polluter and this is facilitated.
So we castigate go companies,
but we go and fill up the
car with petrol or diesel.
You can't have it both ways,
you've got to put it in the frame.
But the bit I would just
want to illustrate is
a lot of companies say,
well, we're investing in
trying to get emissions
out of our production plan.
But you know what, we've
done a load of offsets.
And you really have to look very hard
at what constitutes an offset.
And it looks like nearly half
of what companies are claiming
to be their net zero path
is actually just buying
into renewables projects
many of which would have to happen anyway.
You have to be very careful,
this isn't the religious
version of buying indulgences.
Let me go on doing what I'm doing
but I'll play a side payment
to try to explicate myself.
And that doesn't in any
way detract from the need
for companies to take
this stuff seriously.
But I think this cascade
of people declaring
themselves net zero needs
just a little bit of cautious
and critical examination.
- Agreed, and I throw out as a journalist,
that journalism plays an important role.
They're not just featuring
the announcements,
but asking what's actually happening.
Rory, did you wanna jump
in on this question?
- Yeah.
I think that just to sort of step back
the fundamentals that
we keep coming back to
which I think everybody
keeps emphasizing is that
if the scale of the problem is
as large as we're putting out
and the forms of sacrifice
required are that extreme,
and it's extremely unlikely
that you're gonna be able to do this
without a very significant impact
on growth consumption, et cetera,
it's intuitively very, very unlikely
that private companies are
gonna be able to lead this
for all the reasons that each revenue.
- Thank you, I wanna actually
directly asked this question
around universities especially
because we are wrapping up
for this academic year the
Yale Development Dialogues.
So the question is,
what is the role of our
universities in this whole process
as knowledge and as
dialogue with the world?
So I think that's a good point.
Why are we having this conversation?
And what more can universities do
in terms of helping to
carve the path forward?
Rory, did you wanna jump in?
- Yeah, well, let me comment quickly
as the one person who
really isn't entitled
to speak about this at all
given that I've got three
distinguished professors
on the call.
But for me as somebody
who was a politician
until very recently and
I'm now at a university,
it is unbelievably refreshing and valuable
to be able to have these
types of conversation.
I mean, the last 45 minutes conversation
simply doesn't happen in
politics for 10,000 reasons
to do with the way that elections work,
the attention deficit of politicians,
the general mode you're thinking.
If one were able to take simply
the last 45 minutes of conversation
and actually embed it
in the way that Biden
or Boris Johnson or Macron
thinks about the world
but it makes the most
extraordinary difference.
That's why for me at least
universities are incredibly useful
because it allows you to say
things which are totally brutal
because I can also show you
as an ex working politician
at least six things that everybody said
which would ruin their political careers
in the last 45 minutes.
- I love it, thank you, Rory.
Do others want to jump in on
this, the role of universities?
I guess a question for me is
how do we pull these
kinds of conversations
into the halls of government
into the heads of policy makers
as they're navigating
these hard decisions?
- I goes both ways round, isn't it?
I mean, give you an example,
just a few hundred yards from here,
a group of scientists got
hold of the genetic frame map
of the coronavirus,
and within just over a week
had invented a vaccine.
You don't get that anywhere else
because you don't get that
independent long-term research.
Do you know the ultimate
driver of economic growth
and actually the ultimate driver of hope
to address climate change is ideas.
And ideas are not always
produced in universities,
but it's damn hard to drive them forward
without universities
and without engaging
with the next generation
who are gonna inherit this planet
and hopefully with a few
more natural capital assets
that we're currently
on course to lead them.
- Sunil, go ahead.
- A few things.
In terms of that interface
between these kinds of discussions
and the world of policy,
my main source of optimism
in general is our students.
I mean, I think they are the main conduit
between the kinds of conversations
that we can have in the
classroom and many of them
will go on to be
journalists and politicians
and policymakers.
And so that for me remains the
single most important thing
that universities do is the teaching
as well as research, of course.
As someone in the humanities,
I've been involved with
a lot of conversations
with so many of my colleagues
about how we fold climate change
completely into what we do.
Not as a sort of just
another topic that we study,
but how do we rethink the humanities.
With the climate crisis
sort of very foremost
of our consciousness,
I think there are a lot of conversations
happening around that.
But the last thing I want to say
about universities and climate change
picking up on many things
that have been said in this conversation
is we need some honesty about that too.
I'm not sure that universities
pay for that carbon footprints.
I'm not sure particularly universities
like Yale and others with
very large endowments
have fully thought through
the responsibilities
on that side of things.
- Thank you, Sunil.
And we just have a few minutes left.
So I wanna close with one question
and I'm sorry for those great questions
we weren't able to get to.
A lot of good questions coming in.
But COP26 has come up a few times.
And some of our panelists
have discussed that
we have these meetings,
commitments are made,
and yet as Dieter mentioned
earlier, emissions continue.
Like we start to lose hope in the process.
So with COP26 around the corner
taking place in the context of COVID-19,
we only have about 30 seconds
or so from each of you.
But what's one thing
you want to see happen.
What could rich and poor countries do
between now and November?
Or I should broaden it
since we talked about it,
it's not just a matter of geography.
What should citizens do
between now and November?
Whether it's citizens,
whether it's policymakers,
what's one thing you want to
see to improve the prospects
for real progress to be made at COP26.
And maybe we'll start with our co-hosts
and then conclude with
Dieter, if that's all right.
Rohini can I begin with you?
- Sure.
This is also trying to just
pick up on one of the questions
in the Q&A.
I think what can we didn't touch upon
that I think is gonna be critical
that we start seeing honest conversations
on is the area of carbon
capture and storage.
I think most models of growth right now
that try to be sustainable
are built on large amounts
of sequestration of CCS happening.
We don't understand anything about
I think of the economics of it,
how it's going to be achieved,
how will this happen?
A concern is in something like COP26
that can become the big
thing that everyone says.
We will do a lot more carbon
capture and sequestration
but this is not realistic at all.
So I think having kind of more
honest conversations on that
would be very valuable.
- Thank you, I'll go to Rory
next, if that's all right.
- I think COP26 is really the opportunity
for politicians to do something
that politicians particularly
in an age of populism
find very difficult
which is to get away from cakeism,
get away from having all
cake and being able to eat it
and focusing instead on
detail uncomfortable truths.
And if there's one message
that you want to try to get
it is what we will have to
do is going to have an impact
on our growth and assumption.
If you can just get that
single message through
and suggest to people
that there will be pain
and there will be sacrifice involved,
that's probably the
most important beginning
for this conversation.
- Great point, thank you.
Sunil.
- And honest conversation seemed to be
the theme of our conversation now.
And I think that is what is needed.
As a humanist, I think narrative matters
and what I would like to see citizens
and scholars and activists do
is to find a way of linking
what we've all been through
with this coronavirus pandemic
with a much longer term future.
And the fact that the climate
crisis and the coronavirus
crisis are connected in many, many ways.
And we've been deeply conscious
of one of these crises
and willfully ignoring the
other for the most part.
So I would like to see
stories, narratives,
ways of linking these things
and ways that are meaningful to people.
- Absolutely agree with you.
Dieter, we'll close with your thoughts
on what needs to happen
between now and COP26
for this to really make
a meaningful difference.
- Well, I think that whereas
the politicians all queuing up
to make announcements about numbers
many of which they don't understand
and I'm not against that process,
I would like the concentration
to be shining the torch
on what's really going on.
I would like a reconnection
between natural capital
biodiversity and climate change.
This is a global environmental crisis,
not just a climate one.
I would like the accounting done properly
so we measure who is really
responsible for carbon
and obviously like carbon pricing
'cause I want the polluters to pay.
And finally, I think what
I'd like individuals to do,
citizens to do is write
their own carbon diary
and look very hard into their own lives
and write down how much during
the average day they think
is the carbon emissions
that they are responsible
through their consumption.
And ask themselves how in 30 years time
they're gonna write the same
carbon diary as a citizen
with no carbon in it.
Then they'll get a
measure of the sheer scale
of the task in front of
us which we must address
because if we don't, the
consequences will address us.
- Well, put in a powerful call
to action to close us out.
So it's my task now to wrap up.
This is a fascinating conversation,
thank you to all of our panelists.
And as our 2020, 2021 season
of the Yale Development
Dialogues comes to an end,
we're beginning to plan our series
for the next academic year.
And we would really love all of your input
on the topics we should cover.
So when you exit this webinar,
you'll be linked to a feedback form.
It shouldn't take more than
just a few minutes to fill out.
And as a thank you,
you'll be entered into a drawing
for a collection of books
by different panelists we featured
over the course of this series
including Dieter's latest book,
"Net Zero: How We Stop
Causing Climate Change."
So thank you to all of our panelists
and thanks to all of you for joining us.